r on commence donc par parler du
coronavirus l'inquiétude monte en france
après qu'on ait appris que plusieurs cas
plusieurs centaines même s'était
développée en italie d'où cette question
faut-il que nous fermions nos frontières
alors les responsables politiques sont
assez prudents mais par exemple eric
ciotti qui se trouve être le président
les républicains du département des
alpes maritimes demande dans un tweet
des mesures renforcées de contrôle à la
frontière
la mobilisation des établissements
hospitaliers mais aussi la mise en
oeuvre d'un plan d'urgence dans son
département des alpes maritimes
et puis il ya cette question de la
fermeture éventuelle des frontières
aériennes si air france a suspendu ses
vols avec la chine
il est encore possible de d'atterrir en
france en venant de chine par d'autres
compagnies ce que regrette marine le pen
écoutez moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
m'explique quel est la cohérence qui
consiste à faire revenir des français de
chine pour les mettre en confinement en
quarantaine et dans le même temps
laisser tous les jours des avions en
provenance de chine atterrir sans aucun
contrôle sur ce territoire national
alors ce qu'on peut répondre à marine le
pen c'est que les français rapatriés
venaient de la région du wan qui est
région dont on sait qu'elle est
contaminée et aucun chinois ne peut
sortir de cette région pour venir chez
nous n'empêche que il ya une vraie
inquiétude
jean daniel lévy dans l'opinion est ce
que vous sentez une montée de 2
demande de fermeture supplémentaire de
frontières terrestres aériennes déjà une
inquiétude une suspicion bien doute
l'inquiétude qui existent face au
développement de cette ne s'est
cependant pas de ce qui apparaît aux
yeux des français comme étant une
pandémie
une suspicion disant est ce qu'on nous
dit où véritablement complètement la
vérité en france sur la nature de la
gravité de cette situation
et puis un doute également concernant en
fait la manière dont les autorités
publiques peuvent aujourd'hui prendre la
parole et ça renvoie à des douze convois
de manière généraux quasiment
systématique dès lors qu'il ya des
enjeux de santé qui sont des enjeux de
noces de santé qui se nature à nous
dépasser
collectivement et qui font que on va se
demander si on n'est pas face à un état
d'un point de vue général en face à des
responsables politiques qui vont avoir
tendance à minorer une réalité et quand
marine le pen prend la parole de cette
manière là elle a un écho qui est un
écho assez important en tout cas auprès
d'une part importante de la population
française qui est dans cette forme de
théorie entre le complot d'un côté
l'incapacité où le doute concernant la
sincérité du propos qui a tenu de la
part de ceux qui s'expriment dans
l'espace public vous pouvez vous
rappeler par exemple que lorsqu'il y
avait eu le débat en fait en tout cas le
sras h1n1 une vraie interrogation sur la
manière dont les autorités publiques
avaient pu être amené à prendre et à
tenir compte de la gravité de la
situation et tenir compte en fait des
enjeux pour pouvoir mettre en place le
dispositif qui était à la hauteur des
attentes des français d'okola voilà
c'est ce regard qui est un regard on va
dire aujourd'hui les responsables
politiques sont pas forcément les bons
experts et peut-être qu'ils ne veulent
pas affoler la population française et
ne le disent pas la totalité de la
réalité de ce qui se passe dans notre
pays
alors vous parlez de cette inquiétude on
apprend à l'instant et ça va
probablement pas contribué à la diminuer
que l' oms appelle à se préparer à une
pandémie mondiale à partir du
coronavirus plus voici un autre élément
on vous pose la question sur le site du
figaro pensez vous que la france est
bien préparée en cas d'épidémie
la réponse c'est assez majoritairement
négative à près de 60%
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya
130 mille votants donc ça de toute
évidence ça mobilise les les internautes
georges kuzmanovic votre point de vue
sur ce sujet mon point de vue c'est que
la mondialisation est bien mieux
préparés à ce genre de de pandémie quand
elle quand elle éclate et on vient on
voit bien combien sont embarrassés des
pouvoirs politiques qui ont appliqué des
politiques néolibérales pendant des
années quand on a un ministre de la
santé qui dit qu'il faut se préparer au
combat mais avec l'armée si demain ce
sont des milliers de français qui sont
touchés s'il ya une pandémie
ça peut arriver dans quelques hôpitaux
qu'elle lit centaines des milliers de
lits ont été fermés
alors vous avez vraiment pas les
législatives hier qu'il y avait une
centaine d'hôpitaux qui dansait déjà se
tenait près 8 mai des milliers en ayant
fermé dans les urgences sont en grève
parce qu'ils sont déjà là maintenant
aujourd'hui saturation sans qu'il y ait
une pandémie de ce type là est donc on a
on a un souci
alors je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
jean gagné le daily mail on ad on a
quand même un pays qui se souvient qu'il
a eu le sens cantonne le sang contaminé
et des inquiétudes quant à l'attitude de
ceux qui nous gouvernent
est-ce qu'ils iraient jusqu'au bout les
récemment ne le problème avec lubrizol
est ce qu'ils sont prêts est ce qu'ils
vont dire clairement les choses
or si je sais qu'on nous cache quelque
chose non mais là j'ai su celui qui est
un vendredi dernier ce vendredi est
sorti ce sujet m'intéresse beaucoup
parce que nous on défend la souveraineté
pharmaceutique et c'est un problème que
nous n'ayons pas de dispositif dans
notre pays pour nous prémunir
quand il ya une urgence contre des
pandémies parce que ces choses là
arrivent malheureusement comme il n'y a
pas de fin de l'histoire
beaucoup apprécié fans venus y entrent
dans la composition des médicaments sous
forme ex en chine et ont joué au moins
un doux tout simplement on a pas on n'a
pas les brevets on n'a pas les moyens de
répondre rapidement en cas de en cas en
cas de besoin or
ce qu'on nous dit pour le moment c'est
que l'information qu'on a sur le coran
navires us c'est qu'il est très fait
très aisément transmissibles comme une
grippe normale par voie aérienne mais
qu' il est peu létale or l'analyse faite
par des landes 7 qui est un des
principaux journaux médicaux au monde
revue britannique de ce vendredi montre
qu'on a des risques de létalité à 4% ce
qui là devient extrêmement dangereux des
colossales pour tous pour l'économie
pour le fonctionnement pour le flux
économiques pour les flux des citoyens
au fonctionnement normal de nos pays
très complexe et ils basent sur les
résultats qui vous ne reviennent
d'italie ou des résultats qu'ils ont
d'eux qu'ils ont de chine et je rappelle
celle à qui a eu un problème grave qui
est depuis 2010 est un des problèmes
principaux au niveau de msc les
transformations rapides des des virus et
le problème c'est que ce genre de virus
là ce qui inquiète toujours les
autorités médicales
c'est la mutation du virus en quelque
chose de plus totale voilà je précise
que le taux de létalité c'est le nombre
des personnes touchées par la maladie
qui en meurent jusqu'à présent le taux
était estimé à plus tôt à 2 %
c'est-à-dire un taux un peu supérieur à
celui de la grippe
et effectivement ça a été revue à la
hausse comme vous le disiez vendredi
dernier bertrand payer la question qu'on
se posait c'était faut-il fermer nos
frontières
à titre de précaution ou est-ce que ça
ne ferait qu affoler les populations
je crois que cette crise comme toutes
les crises sanitaires est assez
symptomatique du discrédit de la parole
politique
voilà les plus petits peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent peur disent qu'on ne les
croit pas et donc on nous cache
nécessairement quelque chose évidemment
il se trouve toujours une marine la
peine pour attiser un peu cette ces
braises
alors après oui on peut on peut fermer
les frontières il se trouve que je ne
suis pas du tout un spécialiste de la
question mais je n'imagine pas que les
virus est un visa qu'on pourrait
contrôler à menton pour leur refuser
l'accès et les renvoyer en italie si par
malheur ils se présentaient à notre
frontière
je vois pas bien et puis il faut quand
même pas failli à une personne
hospitalisée en france il y en a une
donc pas je veux bien que on exagère et
qu'on en fasse une montagne il ya une
personne alors après ce qui est assez
intéressant en terme de communication
c'est je pense que le gouvernement a
voulu en faire une communication
exemplaire de crise et communique
énormément
il ya eu encore une réunion à matignon
ce week-end olivier verront le nouveau
ministre de la santé a communiqué en
expliquant que de nouveaux lits allait
être ouvert puisque il y avait 38
hôpitaux qui auparavant étaient
susceptibles d'accueillir des malades du
coronavirus il y en aura désormais 70
les dépistages vont être facilitée
également les masques vont être
commandés en nombre pour le personnel
hospitalier puisque vous sait très bien
que ce sont eux qui ont besoin de
masques et que les gens dans la rue
n'ont pas besoin donc je pense qu'ils
ont voulu faire quelque chose
d'irréprochable et malgré tout ça n'est
jamais suffisant parce que il y a
toujours un fond de méfiance de
suspicion que peut-être on nous
cacherait des choses là a été c'est
quand même qu' il ya une personne
hospitalisée en france pour le corps
devient alors il faut préciser que
contrairement à ce que certains
commentateurs ont dit à mon avis un peu
vite marine le pen au grand jury rtl le
figaro lci n'a pas demandé la fermeture
des frontières à la 10 à partir du
moment où les mesures de confinement en
italie sont sérieusement mise en oeuvre
respecte et il n'y a pas de raison de
fermer la frontière mais peut-être que
ce sera nécessaire si l'épidémie est
hors de contrôle en italie judith
waintraub vous êtes journaliste
politique est ce qui vous paraît
légitime que un sujet comme celui là
fassent l'objet d'un débat où est-ce
qu'ils devraient pas être le monopole
des des spécialistes et des des
responsables sanitaires spécialisés les
responsables sanitaires ont eux aussi
des paroles qui entretiennent et
certaines suspicions et je pense
notamment à l' oms l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui a été beaucoup
critiquée pour avoir tardé à déclarer
l'urgence mondiale il en est mort
l'aféas mois après avoir été informé par
la chine de l'existence d'une épidémie
elle avait refusé de le faire et c'est
c'est responsables tiennent des discours
très teintée de politique où on retrouve
un peu ce que vous avez dit d'ailleurs
c'est pas bien de fermer les frontières
c'est pas bien de d'interdire les
déplacements dont on ne voit pas
pourquoi il aurait le monopole de la
parole publique sur cette question là
d'autant qu'il ya des pays qui agissent
par exemple plus que nous les etats unis
vous savez que les non ressortissants
américains ne peut qui reviennent de
chine ne peuvent plus rentrer aux états
unis et que les ressortissants
américains sont soumis à des périodes de
quarantaine quand ils viennent au moins
des régions les plus directement
concernés
la russie a totalement fermé sa
frontière terrestre avec la chine
donc vraiment des pays qu'ils prennent
des mesures radicales sont rendus aux
urnes au fascisme et au souverainisme né
à la démagogie
je vous confirme l'instant fermé sa
frontière et clients en iran où il ya eu
plusieurs cas je vous rappelle ce que je
vous disais à l'instant le directeur
général de l oms a donc appelé
il ya quelques minutes le monde à se
préparer à une éventuelle pandémie due
nouveau coronavirus il juge très
préoccupante l'augmentation soudaine de
nouveaux cas en italie en corée du sud
et en iran je vous livre les
commentaires et les points de vue de nos
internautes
celui de santé qui nous dit quel que
soit le niveau de préparation le maillon
faible reste l'hôpital on a tendance à
l'oublier mais ça fait un an que les
urgences sont en grève
il manque du personnel dans les hôpitaux
ajoute paul sur le site du figaro
imaginons une épidémie au trouve tant le
personnel soignant dont on a besoin
nicole aimerait bien savoir comment
l'italie en est arrivé à ce nombre
d'infectés et de morne crois qu'on peut
pas répondre à cette question nicole
parce que d'ailleurs le l'italie cherche
activement ont calé le 6-0 6-2 retrouver
vivant le patient 1 mais ils n'arrivent
donc lui ils l'ont isolé il est isolé
les gens avec lesquels il est en contact
régulier mais celui duquel il a récupéré
cette maladie lui n'est visiblement pas
encore identifiés et donc pas encore
circonscrit et isolées
les autorités européennes l'union
européenne elle-même a évoqué cette
question de l'aide de la fermeture des
frontières mais pour l'instant n'était
pas envisagé d'y procéder mais que ce
n'était pas exclue donc c'est pas du
tout réservé à marine le pen n'ont pas
choisi combien de contrats pour l' oms
il faut quand même leur travail une
pandémie dangereuse de grippe et quelque
chose qu'ils attendent
statistiquement devrait on devrait
dedans dans cette décennie où on est
actuellement celle qui est régulièrement
elle touche l'humanité et fédère
énormément énormément de dégâts on pense
à la grippe à la grippe espagnole
ma grand mère qui est connu tout petit
la la première guerre mondiale ce sera
plaît surtout de la panique qui avait
provoqué la grippe espagnole et un plan
qu'elle avait fait plus de victimes
c'est dans un monde c'est en 1910
semblait mort voilà dans un monde
agricole 1 100 avions sang transporte ce
qu'on a actuellement mais ça non plus
les mêmes capacités de santé aujourd'hui
pour vous soigner
d'ailleurs il ya une autre question
celle de clair obscur sur figaro live
qui nous ce qu'ils demandent combien de
personne tue pas rend la grippe
ordinaire alors en france est environ
dix mille mais ça dépend des années
donc évidemment c'est beaucoup plus que
le corps aux navires us sauf que
celui-ci n'ait d en activité si je puis
dire que depuis un plus d'un mois il ya
même des mesures de confinement des
élèves j'ai vu ça dans des lycées du
xiiie arrondissement
les gens qui reviennent de chiffres
c'est la fin des vacances scolaires dans
une un quartier avec beaucoup de
personnes d'origine chinoise
lycée claude monet dans le xiiie a dit
aux gens qui revenaient de chimie de
rester chez eux comme certains
maîtrisent absolument commentaires
darcos bien ça vous fait beaucoup réagir
ce sujet surfer your life quelle est la
durée de vie du virus avant mutation
quand on sait pas on ne dit pas je lui
dit vous avez une ne sait pas on croyait
au début avec une période de quarantaine
de 14 jours on était dans les mesures de
prudence qui s'impose et puis là il
semblerait que ce sera plus long et on
sait pas en plus dans quelle mesure un
patient asymptomatique c'est à dire
qu'ils nous présentent pas de symptômes
de la maladie est contagieux ou pas
burns le figaro là il veut demande une
fermeture des frontières immédiate
pourquoi attendre la pandémie dit-il
baby loup n'est pas de cet avis même
s'il ya une pandémie nationale on a les
structures suffisantes pour gérer ce
virus c'est que bertrand perri étaient
impatients d'avoir le point de vue
depuis toujours apprécié d'avoir le
point de vue de vignes le voilà et puis
marianne qui estime que la france est
mal préparée car elle n'a pas mis en
place des mesures de vérification des
statistiques sur strass oui alors vous
savez que beaucoup considèrent au
contraire que le système de santé
français a beaucoup appris des
précédents phénomène de type grippe
aviaire h1n1 et puis voilà fois qu'on
s'est tous dit ah si une dernière
question d'arcus au figaro live quand
va-t-on trouver un vaccin contre le
coronavirus il me semble que l'institut
pasteur avait dit que ça prendrait six
mois mais voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
sur ce sujet encore une fois ou donne un
point de vue sans être forcément des
spécialistes médicaux souvenez que par
exemple sur ce plateau
il y a
une grosse semaine le docteur pelo
urgentistes vous êtes état d'une
relative d'un 12 sur la gravité de la
pandémie finalement peut-être que tout
le monde même les gens qui connaissent
le sujet sont un peu pris de vitesse par
ce qui se passait en espérant qu'on peut
dire une chose quand même en espérant
qu'il n'y a rien de grave au final avec
sont pas si catastrophiques on peut se
dire que ça serait bien d'avoir un
financement correct des hôpitaux
d'écouter le personnel hospitalier de
refinancer secteur est d'avoir une
capacité d'état en propre de riposte sur
les questions pharmaceutique et on
rappelle que pour le céder à un autre
débat amorcé dès que vous avez plein de
gens y compris des médecins qui disent
que le problème principal des hôpitaux
c'est pas un problème financier auprès
de l'organisation c'est un peu
effectivement un autre des neuf on a
déjà eu et qu'on en fera sûrement à
nouveau et puis je rappelle cette
information c'est quand même l'essentiel
pour l'instant il ya une personne
touchée en france par le coronavirus
alors que la grippe tue environ dix
mille citoyens français chaque année on
change totalement de sujet pour parler
du procès fillon on attendait le début
des audiences
aujourd'hui finalement